Ochs calm recently published a
nauseatingly sycophantic piece written
by a reporter who had just traveled to
China it turns out on the Chinese
government's Dhanam over at Jeff Bezos
as Washington Post
you'll periodically see an entire insert
called China watch it looks like a new
section it reads like the rest of the
paper in fact it's literally a product
of chinese state media they paid to
place it just as they paid it influenced
numerous think tanks around washington
as well as many colleges and
universities throughout the country it's
a huge propaganda push that is almost
never noted by anybody and it costs a
lot but over time it's worth it the
Chinese get what they pay for a
compliant American establishment that
uses fake threats manufactured threats
from Russia to obscure real and imminent
threats from China turns out there
really are traitors in Washington but
they're not working for the Kremlin
Julian I've seen is a former chief
counsel for Democrats on the House
Judiciary Committee and he joins us
tonight so join you and I both live in
Washington and we know personally a lot
of people who are in effect on the
Chinese payroll Madeleine Albright has
made a lot of money from China John
Bainer the former Republican speaker
works for a firm that lobbies for China
Jim Wolfensohn and the World Bank
advises the Chinese sovereign wealth
fund etc etc etc how many people do you
know who are openly working for Russia
in Washington I think your basic point
that the Chinese are a greater long-term
threat to us then Russia is I think
that's true I think in the 1970s China
had about 1 percent of the flows of
world trade they now have about 25
percent right about 2 percent of the
global economy in within the decade they
will be equal to the size of the US
economy by 2050 they will be twice the
size of the US economy I think we
thought when we brought them into the
World Trade Organization into in 2001
that it would help them play fair and I
think what we've seen since then is that
they've cheated they've stolen
intellectual property up until 2014 they
were certainly manipulating the currency
I don't think they play by the rules and
I think one of the things I agree with
the President on is they get tough with
China I would approach it differently
than he does but I think he's right to
get tough on China I think the media
ought to focus more on it it's not as
sensational so it's not going to get
ratings on cable television but it's a
real problem the disappearing middle
class and working class is a real
problem it's not sensational it's not
gonna be a sugar high for cable
television so you I don't think you're
gonna have any of the network's not this
network not CNN not MSNBC any of them
focusing on those issues because you
just don't get the sugar high from that
that's not to say Russia isn't a threat
I mean Russia has done lots of things
all of our intelligence agencies and
Republican and Democratic
administrations afraid that even though
they're 1% of the world economy they
still to drop lots of things that are
directly oppositional to us and that are
trying to destabilize our interests
whether it's in the Middle East whether
it's in Syria whether it's in the
Balkans whether it's in the UK it
doesn't mean that they're not a real
threat and there's not something to take
seriously but I think your basic point
is correct which is that we are sleeping
while Rome burns with respect to China
and we have not taken seriously the fact
that they don't play by the rules we
have wait so I'm waiting to jump in with
a hostile question but you're making my
case for me you've taken we're mad at
them in the statements because I think
you're absolutely right so suing has a
metathesis okay because I have a thesis
it's hard to and thank you for being
honest about that and I by the way it's
not a partisan thing there are a ton of
Republicans working on behalf of China
I'm embarrassed to say and Democrats are
finally waking up I think that there is
a real threat that China does not play
by the rules and that it's something to
take very presidential
outrage about Russia and Saudi Arabia
and neither of which I've ever been in
favor of by the way I'm not carrying
water for either one but the idea that a
country we are allied with assassinates
one of its political opponents yeah it's
bad but I mean that is a fact like daily
occurrence in China and no one says
anything about it and I just wonder
should we treat the people in Washington
who have a lot of power who are getting
rich from China should we treat them as
traitors in the same way that we treat
anyone who deals with Russia as a
traitor I look I think your point about
even-handedness is well taken I think
the Chinese do horrible things to
journalists and to dissidents and they
and they get a pass on it I think in a
lot of cases the social media Giants
Facebook and Google enable a lot of the
bad behavior that's going on a lot
autocratic regimes we don't hear that
much about it although that's starting
to get covered I think if your point is
proportionality it does the news and
particularly cable news does it cover
these things in the proper
proportionality I agree with that meta
point that you're making it doesn't mean
to say that when the Saudis go and kill
an American journalist we shouldn't be
getting tough on the Saudis it doesn't
mean to say if the Russians create a
military intelligence attack on the
United States that that's not something
we should seriously and we shouldn't and
we should get to the bottom of that but
I think your basic point is that you
know there is selective outrage there is
a lot of chest stepping there's a lot of
kind of you know morally superior
indignation that that occurs on the
Russia issue and you know you and I may
have slightly different views I'm trying
are you Chilean FC but it's it's proving
absolutely you did a better job than I
could have been you know there's a lot
of self-righteousness on certain issues
and I think there's reason to be upset
about what happened with Russia there's
reason to be upset with Saudi Arabia but
I think if you're gonna be outraged on
those issues your point is correct that
you should be equally outraged on the
abuses that are occurring and shine that
accuses and China are very very serious
and you're exactly right about that so
we Epstein thank you very much